[Música]
vamos a la revista de prensa esta mañana
con Rosa Pérez más deu Rosa Buen día
para usted Hola Ángela Buenos días Bueno
vamos a empezar hablando de la región
latinoamericana después es de las
elecciones estatales que en el Estado de
México y en Coahuila vamos a empezar con
las portadas de la prensa de ese país si
le parece exactamente y como bien lo
decías Ángela estas elecciones tuvieron
lugar en dos estados no Estado de México
y Coahuila sin embargo como el estado de
México tiene un importantísimo peso
demográfico a nivel Federal no a nivel
de todo México digamos que los
resultados la victoria de morena del
oficialismo en ese estado es el más
destacado en la prensa mexicana e
internacional porque digamos que la
lectura es que favorece al oficialismo
de Cara a las elecciones legislativas y
presidenciales de 2024 bien empezamos
por El Universal de México que dice
morena arrebata el estado de México y el
pri mantiene Coahuila no un poco lo que
decíamos y señala que Delfina la
candidata del partido de Andrés Manuel
López Obrador del presidente de morena y
en la nueva gobernadora del Estado de
México dice acaba con 100 años de
dominio priista En este estado que como
decíamos es el más poblado del país 16
millones de habitantes y por lo tanto el
que tiene mayor peso demográfico a nivel
electoral no tenemos también el
excelsior de México que dice arrebatan
bastión al pri en la misma línea y
arranca la sucesión de cara al 2024 no
con la incertidumbre sin embargo de que
líderes dentro del oficialismo se van a
perfilar para suceder a Andrés a Manuel
López Obrador eventualmente y dice
ventaja de los partidos del 4t no 4t el
gobierno de la cuarta transformación
este gobierno de López Obrador Tenemos
también El Milenio que dice el Estado de
México jubila al pri Y al pan recordemos
el partido de Acción Nacional mientras
Coahuila resiste a morena bien y después
cerramos esta línea de periódicos
mexicanos con el diario de Yucatán que
dice jornada sin sorpresa un titular
poco entusiasta pero lo un poco lo que
se esperaba y muy realista Rosa el país
que tiene redacción y también una
edición mexicana dedica también varios
resultados a varios artículos a los
resultados de México exactamente y la
lectura es muy parecida no dice la
victoria de Morena en el Estado de
México afianza la hegemonía de Lope de
Obrador recordemos que sin embargo el
actual presidente no se puede volver a
presentar y también ha destacado pues
cualquier digamos táctica estrategia
para intentarlo también dice el país en
morena consolida su poder territorial de
nuevo de Cara a las elecciones de 2024 Y
es que aquí estamos viendo en este en
estas títulos en estos artículos del
país este mapa no de México y vemos de
rojo los estados donde gobierna o
gobernará después del resultado en el
Estado de México pues morena no y vemos
que digamos domina el rojo todo bien
Dice el partido de López Obrador rompe
una nueva Barrera y llegará a las
presidenciales con más poder que nunca
en sus 10 años de vida y señala un poco
este artículo que el territorio mexicano
se va rindiendo a sus pies a lo largo de
esta década como si no hubiera otro
digamos otro camino para el desarrollo
de las cosas no dice son ya 23 gobiernos
estatales de 32 estados y en estos 23
estados dice es son el hogar de más de
92 millones de habitantes es decir este
dato es impactante tres de cada cuatro
mexicanos vive en regiones gobernadas
por morena otra forma de verlo de cada
mil votantes en el país 120 entre 12530
están en el Estado de México y Ángela
Para cerrar con este bloque dedicado a
los resultados de las elecciones de
México otro ángulo que no podía faltar
en el análisis también lo tiene el país
y está firmado por Sonia Corona que dice
hay gobernadora en el Estado de México
en referencia Delfina Gómez no pero nos
quedaron a las mujeres recordamos que el
estado de México es el estado con mayor
tasa de feminicidios de todo México que
ya tiene uno de los más altos de la
región no y escribe Corona a pesar de
que las dos candidatas que se disputaban
la gobernación del Estado eran mujeres y
aquí detrás lo tenemos ninguna de las
dos abordó una propuesta para combatir
las causas esenciales de la violencia de
género no y señala que es posible que de
Cara a las presidenciales veamos una
campaña también protagonizada por
mujeres y que en ese momento Pues será
una nueva oportunidad ojalá que no
desaprovechada de demostrar que los
partidos políticos tienen realmente en
la agenda políticas feministas y que no
son puramente Pues un elemento de
marketing No no es que por muy
importantes que sean no siempre las
candidatas mujeres van a representar
candidaturas feministas exactamente muy
bien Rosa vamos a hacer un cambio de
tema Hoy es el Día Mundial del medio
ambiente France 24 se engalana para
hablar y analizar este tema y en ese
contexto se conoció la noticia de una
acusación formal de uno de los presuntos
autores intelectuales del asesinato hace
un año recordemos del periodista
británico Don Phillips y de el experto
indigenista brasileño y activista Bruno
Pereira de Guardian nos habla sobre este
tema nos lo explica además pues hoy más
que nunca tenemos que recordarlo
exactamente y además de Guardian era un
periódico donde colaboraba don Philips
no el periodista asesinado junto con
Bruno Pereira como tú bien lo decías el
activista y conocedor del territorio que
lo acompañaba bien pues coincidiendo
además con el aniversario de este
lamentable asesinato
se conoce que la policía de Brasil acusa
formalmente a dos personas que fueron
identificadas por una información
adelantada por la televisión globo de
Brasil Que serían Rubén Darío da Silva
Villar que tiene el sobrenombre conocido
como Colombia que sería el presunto
líder de una red transnacional de pesca
ilegal que operaba en la triple frontera
entre Brasil Colombia y Perú y él estaba
acusado digamos de ser el autor
intelectual del crimen de ordenar los
asesinatos y el ocultamiento de los
cuerpos por otro lado está acusado
freitas de Sousa quien era un pescador
digamos dedicado a la pesca ilegal
subordinado al primer de los acusados y
esta digamos el acusado de participar en
ambos delitos bien entre las pruebas que
hay en el sumario de la investigación de
la policía de Brasil y es que los dos
acusados se habrían llamado 419 veces
entre el 1 de junio cuando los la pareja
de asesinados llegaron al territorio y
el día después del 6 de junio el día
después de haber sido asesinados también
hay imágenes de una tarjeta de una
imagen que bueno es bastante digamos
impactante imaginarla Y es que bueno hay
imágenes del periodista británico Don
Philips hablando intentando conversar
con el que sería su presunto asesino
justo en la mañana antes de que
ocurriera el crimen para finalizar hoy
en Brasil y en Reino Unido hay actos de
homenaje y de recuerdo no a los a los
dos fallecidos
pues mire Rosa América Latina es la
región más peligrosa para ser líder
social la región del mundo más peligrosa
para ser mujer y también la región del
mundo más peligrosa para ser
ambientalista y que nos quede claro pues
en esta fecha que deberíamos revertir
esa realidad Muchas gracias a usted
exactamente Ángela Muchas gracias a ti
hasta mañana